Made it a sunnah that the be
made with and without tarjir.
The that we usually hear in
most of our lives is without
what is called or echoing the
what's meant by echoing here is
that this is something that the
prophet taught about and Abu
Mahadura is one of his four
more evidence that he had in
Mecca. He had two in Mecca and
two in Medina. One of the in
Mecca. Abu Mahadura, he taught
him a Tarjir to make an
[Silence]
then and then he would continue
with the as normal starting
with
so in account, it's as if he is
echoed twice, right?
known and it's not something
that is done very often though
I have heard of some Northern
African countries that still
practice this. Either way is
the son of the prophet likewise
another sunnah in the way that
he made was that the would be
made exactly as the is made.
The exact same way with the
addition of as we know. Also,
basically half of that. So,
saying every statement once as
we usually hear such as in this
masjid. However, the phrase it
is always said twice in the
Akama. There's no version of
the with it being said only
once. It is always said twice.
Likewise, the prophet
What is authentic of his
sunnah? Is that the is always
said at least twice in the it's
never been authentically
narrated that the at the
beginning was only once.
Likewise, the prophet taught
his and encouraged his and his
followers to do five things
when hearing the Adan. So, the
is making the there are five
things that we have been
encouraged to do. during and
after the event. Call out.
[Silence]
Allah.
saying both of them. Rather, it
is, it is just that to say
[Silence]
and we say instead okay. The
second thing that he mentions
is that a person says
right? And he informed us that
whoever
Now, when do we say this? We
say this after the before the
first so when the says,
and then goes on to say between
these two, we say
this narration is in Muslim.
So, when the says,
[Silence]
time or occasion but it's
something that's been narrated
to us from the prophet and his
name comes up in it, right?
Should we add the statements?
to it? The answer is no. We
don't add this statement,
right? and this is very often
because we only say when it
comes to and when it comes to
dua that have been transmitted
to us from the prophet. We only
say exactly what he said.
Exactly what he taught us.
Because the companions were
taught with extreme precision
by the prophet exactly what to
say when it comes to dua and
when it comes to so if a person
is making a dua and it's a dua
that is from the prophet he
doesn't add anything to it. And
he doesn't take any part of it
away. Right? And this happens
often. We we hear this often.
It's a common mistake. So for
instance in
right In we often hear a lot of
imams in Ramadan for instance
when they're making this dua.
They add little things into it.
Nothing should be added to it.
It should be exactly as it was
narrated, right?
A lot of times we hear
is not part of the dua. It
shouldn't be it.
Right?
[Silence]
transmitted to us. If a person
is making, formulating his own
dua, his own expression, that's
fine. But if we're, if we are
making a dua that was narrated
to us, we keep it exactly how
it is. We don't add anything
into it. Even if it is, a salah
upon the prophet we don't add
that, right? And and
We have the way that the
prophet would start and
[Silence]
as they were transmitted to us.
We don't add anything to them
and this is common. I mean, if
the is making a then, did you
ever hear
[Arabic recitation]
of the, right? Likewise in
Teshehud, a she Allah,
Muhammad, and Sallallahu Alaihi
Wa Sallam, our
[Silence]
transmitted. We don't add
anything even a salah upon the
prophet
A fairlith one
[Silence]
do it in salah, right?
[Arabic recitation]
This is one way of
[Silence]
to make a salah upon the
prophet what's meant is this,
this wording here, what we hear
in right? So, for instance, he
says, whoever makes a salah
upon me, ten times in the
morning and ten times in the
evening, then, his my
intercession is binding for
this person. What's meant by a
salah here is Allah Muhammad
[Arabic recitation]
and so on. So, wherever we see
in the in the sunnah or in the
Quran for that matter, making a
salah upon the prophet, we say
it in that way, right? Unless
it's in just speaking, in just
speaking.
is acceptable. Allah All of
this is is correct.
[Silence]
A lover